shot with 23 free throws in that fourth
quarter what you thank you Doug thank
you Doug that's that's that's outrageous
what happened tonight this is completely
BS this is shame shame for the referees
shame for the league to allow this 23
free throws for them and we get two free
throws in in a fourth quarter like how
to play the game I all I understand uh
respect for all stars and all that but
we have star players on our team as well
how's possible that Scotty Barnes who is
Allstar caliber player in this league he
goes every single time to the rim with
force and trying to get get to to the
rim without flopping and and not trying
to get foul calls he gets two uh three
throws for a whole game how is that
possible how you going to explain it
that that to me they had to win tonight
if that's if that's the case just let us
no so we don't show up for the game just
give them a win but that that was not
fair tonight and this is not happening
first time for us Scotty Barnes is going
to be all star he's going to be the face
of this league and what what's happening
over here during whole season I've been
holding it back it's a complete
crap do you feel like you're getting any
explanations at all that offensive foul
did you did you see like get any
explanations no no there is no
explanation they just they just come up
there they review what and they see what
they want to see they don't want to hear
us what we got to say they don't want to
hear the players they they they don't
just want to protect us over the game
they got 36 free throws 23 free throws
in in the fourth quarter what are we
talking about what are we talking about
how are we going to supposed to
play this a a one off do you feel this
has been happening to your team a lot
throughout the season it's happening a
lot but I'm telling our guys be
professional keep fighting keep going
for the next one but until when for how
long
else thank you thank
you